hey guys lord cognito here with uh some
unfortunate news i definitely uh want to
speak to you everyone in the realm and
um as you know ilp we're pretty big and
we've got a lot of clan members and
associates and friends and this one goes
out to one particular friend in
particular from uh growing up from back
in the day since our channel five days
lord sinister
many of you may be familiar with him
he's always playing destiny with us in
the ilp clan
if you played uh or you've been in xbox
live party chats with with me and
anybody from the the ilp fam you know
the sinister name he's always in the
chats always having fun and um probably
helped you in a raid or two
but uh unfortunately we're sad to
announce that you know his mother
um recently passed away this morning and
uh we definitely want to send our loves
and thoughts and condolences to his
family to him as you know his beautiful
wife and son and children and then
obviously his mom which we lost he lost
suddenly and this year has been a rough
year for him it's particularly because
uh in april he lost his dad to covert
complications
and his grandmother as well so um
if anything the realm could do
you know when a fallen lord has fallen
down and going through a tough time you
know we want to reach out and we want to
help as best as we can so i'm putting
this out there call of arm to the realm
says help our brother lord sinister aka
garda ortiz good friend i've known this
kid you know since uh back in the south
bronx just playing games good guy and
going through some tough times so
whatever we can do to help would be
greatly appreciated and to really send
off his family the right way so it's
lord cognito here again any help is
appreciated and thank you for your time